1848 was a pretty rough year for many
european rulers it saw revolutions in
places like france the german
confederation the austrian empire and
sardinia the revolution sought to
improve living conditions settle
nationalist questions and fix government
deficiencies and despite having problems
with all of these britain did not have a
revolution or even an attempt at one in
1848 which raises the question why why
was britain spared a revolution where
much of europe wasn't so lucky so to
begin despite not having a revolution
the british people shared many of the
same grievances with their government as
those across the channel
industrialization had seen the rise of
poor working conditions many were
annoyed at the lack of political
representation and in ireland and wales
there were many who felt aggrieved by
the way westminster was running things
much of this sprang from the 1832 reform
acts which notably expanded the
electorate but only to land owners and a
few others meaning most men still
couldn't vote which unsurprisingly upset
them opposition began to organize via
working men's clubs whose members called
for more rights and better conditions
leaders of these clubs along with some
members of parliament met to draft what
was called the people's charter this
pushed for the british government to
radically change the way that parliament
worked so after the charter was
published it was promptly ignored this
was mostly because doing stuff is
annoying and the current system works
well for everyone in power so why bother
tensions rose over the following decade
and the government had to deal with
riots and strikes across the country the
leader of the chartist movement fergus
o'connor was elected an mp in 1847 and
probably began to demand change in the
house of commons nothing did change
though and when news reached britain
about the revolutions abroad the
chartists saw their chance o'connor
arranged for a large march to carry a
petition to parliament which organizers
claimed had over 5 million signatures
which for a nation of 26 million people
was quite a lot the government got wind
of this and remembering what happened in
france they wanted to be sure that there
was no threat to the british government
or the crown and they knew that the
presentation to parliament was when the
danger of revolution would be at its
greatest headed by the duke of
wellington soldiers were placed all
across london just out of sight of the
planned route and thus they wouldn't be
provoking anyone but they'd be able to
respond if anything went wrong the
government also hired an extra 100 000
special constables who were voluntary
police officers whose training consisted
of his attraction go hit someone with it
interestingly among the hundred thousand
officers recruited were former prime
minister robert peel and some guy called
louis napoleon bonaparte who would later
go on to find gainful employment in
france these extra men would prove
unnecessary though since the march in
parliament would never happen the
chartists weren't planning to violently
overthrow the government and their
leaders had faced down troops before so
why didn't they march it wasn't muskets
or truncheons that stopped them it was
the rain you see rights and reformers
were important but nobody wanted to
fight for them whilst wet and with the
coming of the rain the demonstrators
just sort of went home the petition was
delivered to parliament by a couple of
chartists and was promptly ignored turns
out most of the signatures were
forgeries and the chartist movement were
so thoroughly embarrassed that it never
recovered the chance for revolution was
gone but in the end most of the chartist
demands were adopted by the british
parliament eventually i hope you enjoyed
this episode and a special thanks to my
patrons james bisonette kelly money
maker sky chappelle corsa wolff jerry
lamdin jordan longley adam stalter
marcus arsenault wyan hockey spencer
lightfoot rod demart in words about
books podcast captain cydog gustav swan
marvin castle common yoon winston k wood
boogie wiggly daniel to be in miss
izzette matthew shipley aaron the white
corey turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski she went in spinning three
plates and charles the first